[Applaudissements]
c'est florent peyre il fait deviner eric
antoine qui bien là le problème avec
eric antoine c'est qu'on ne voit plus
les crocs
est-ce que vous allez le voir comment
attention attention 10 mauricie aurès et
leur expliquions jour on est prêt je
suis comme un foutage il faut qu'il eric
je ne perds jamais qu'un jeu vous avez
le choix entre cheveux au vent ou 24
heures avec jean michel maire qu'est ce
que voulait comme thème florent vous
devez prendre une voix suave de
téléphone rose pour lui faire deviner
les mots à trèbes être moins rapidement
je vais faire comme la fouille alors
[Rires]
bienvenue au téléphone mon pote comme
talamonti coup et se marrer pas de moi
c'est que c'est d'accord attention c'est
parti premier jour ce sont des endroits
où on va pour danse et à la musique très
fort et un club non fiscaux c'est qu'en
français un boîte de nuit
deuxièmement alors quand on enlève tous
ses habits pour exciter une personne
infectée 2 pour le troisième mot quand
on va avoir des rapports mais qu'on veut
qu'il soit protégé en est un qui a
préservé de ciseaux un poids quatrième
au hockey pour tenir les niches on est
un soutien gorge
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]